Edward's syndrome is a genetic condition
where the infants are born with an extra
copy of chromosome 18. these children
show Heart and Lung abnormalities
decreased muscle tone overlapping
fingers and Club shift feet the extra
copy of chromosome 18 is due to a
process known as non-disjunction during
the meiosis Division II generally one
copy of 8 chromosome 18 comes from
father and mother but in this case two
copies might be present in mother that
leads to a zygote with three copies of
chromosome 18 and that leads to the
problem
processes like amniocentesis and
chorionic Village sampling and followed
by karyotyping can give us an idea about
that extra chromosome 18. this is a
diagnostic method there is no treatment
for disease and these child do not
survive till the adolescence
and here is a cool mnemonic to remember
the Edward syndrome
watch the full video to know more